papa son petit livre il a toujours
préservé bien bien proprement dans le ce
critère non non non si t'es pas dans les
greniers du tout du tout du tout
témoigner raconter l'horreur de la
guerre vécue par son père amputé à 22
ans en 1940 colette c'en est fait un
devoir alors aujourd'hui elle explique à
ceux qui viennent voir l'exposition
consacrée à la collecte des témoignages
et objet de la deuxième guerre mondiale
que donner c'est aussi rendre hommage à
ceux qui l'ont vécue quand on donne
c'est vraiment une action de de donner
du sens de la vie qui venait tout d'un
coup ce harnais wyss a une histoire et
puis ça rejaillit et puis son histoire à
lui elle va être honoré le père de
christiane lui a été arrêté en 43 alors
qu'ils tentaient de rejoindre de gaulle
il a passé plus de deux ans au camp
dorian bourque sachsenhausen et les
quelques traces qu'il a laissées à ses
enfants sa fille les gardent
précieusement comme cette dédicace sur
la première page d'un livre qu'il aura
offert à mon fils michel costi pour
qu'il se souvienne
donc durant deux ans six mois huit jours
une émotion encore vives qui a jusque-là
empêcher christiane de se séparer des
objets ayant appartenu à son père traces
du calvaire qu'il a vécu et longtemps
gardé pour lui
quand ils sont arrivés les gens ils
voulaient plus entendre parler de la
guerre d'une part on ne les croyait pas
on croyait pas toutes ses horreurs donc
en fait ils se sont tus se sont tus
pendant des années donné au musée c'est
pour elle transformer son histoire
intime en mémoire collective maintenant
je me tiens par l'étape suivante c'est 2
de transmettre s'armer de patience
pour le devoir de mémoire cette
exposition c'est vraiment dire aux gens
ne laisse ne laissait pas partir
l'histoire dans les poubelles depuis sa
création plus de 1500 donateurs ont
ainsi confié leur patrimoine au musée de
la résistance et de la déportation